[Music]
all right Pacific grin man I am pumped
to talk about this movie I can tell the
only problem is how do we decide who's
gonna do the prose and who's gonna do
the cons what do you mean only if both
gonna want to do the prose so yeah how
do we choose do we flip a coin or why do
not mind doing the comments all right
doesn't bother me you you
didn't like Pacific Rim no that's not
even remotely what I said I just saw
enough wrong with it but I don't mind
taking the con side in an artist you
okay whatever I'm going first though do
it you go first the robot drives up in
cargo ship through the streets of Hong
Kong and beats up a giant alien monster
with it
yeah that's pretty awesome that was easy
it's my turn now that's only awesome at
the expensive flick story and character
what like it's so obviously spent so
much time on the robots they just had an
intern and want you to menu roland
emmerich movies do the screen right man
look what is the new script exterior day
robot punches monster it's about how
they approached it like it couldn't have
any more cliches in this movie if they
try will the two new partners get along
will they fall in love will the grizzled
veteran come out of retirement and save
the day well the scientists storyline
make me want to choke none of those
questions had good answers yeah I liked
all that stuff are you you mean to tell
me that you knew they were gonna fall in
love like in the beginning of the movie
cuz I didn't see that coming at all
that's only because you were too busy
masturbating to the robot fights I did
that when I got home all right I am an
adult whatever that's my point
all right my turn again
the robot drags up in cargo ship through
the streets of Hong Kong and beats up a
giant alien monster with it no
you already use them worth more than
just one pillow it's not not according
to the rules I'm telling you cz
I'm sorry now let's talk about the
accents for a second accents talk about
the xn citrus elbow specifically that
guy's a god of accents I watched all
five seasons of The Wire twice before I
even knew he was British but what the
hell is up with his accent in this movie
it's like Scottish at times and English
at times and a little Australian South
African it's all over the place it's
really distracting I didn't notice I
just I was too busy paying attention to
the badass locker room speakers if you
didn't notice the accent then you can't
argue against that that was easy
now one's mine too alright my turn okay
the badass locker room speeches you know
kind of glad you did that actually
because the speeches are indeed terrible
like they're cheesy there's one speed
towards just him and the other guy
talking in a room and he starts
screaming all the sudden like there's a
thousand guys needing to be inspired
it's ridiculous I have to go thank you
back I argue back the speeches were
inspiring to me dude what do you want
from a giant robot punching aliens movie
like Oscar caliber acting I wish you
could hear how you sound right now you
sound exactly like those people who
defend their love of the Transformers
movies by saying basically the same
thing look I don't mind if the movie
wants to say hey there's a crack in the
ocean and aliens can come through it and
then never address it again that's fine
with me
I don't care if they want to say you
know robot fighting is more important to
us than character development but it's
fine with me but even that don't take me
seriously fun casual movie could still
be made well don't you think the robot
drags a cargo ship through the streets
of Hong Kong and beats up a giant alien
monster with it man you were the reason
they're gonna make six more of these
things over the next ten years sounds
awesome to me
Pacific Rim two more rimming and I'm all
over the Pacific Rim two more inception
sounds okay that was a little distracted
wow how many people do you think stay
for they have to credit scene in this
movie
Pacific Rim has an after credit scene